We can avoid the unrecognized
selector error
by using optional chaining when we call
methods on objects of type AnyObject.
Method calls on objects of type
AnyObject can be treated as implicitly
unwrapped optionals.
Here, the call to openDoor
will just silently fail.
Placing the question mark after openDoor
is equivalent to conditioning on a call
to the method responds to
selector in Objective-C.
If we want some notice
when this method fails,
because the method call acts like
an implicitly unwrapped optional,
we can use if let to handle
two different conditions.
Another prudent alternative for
handling objects of type AnyObject,
is to cast them to a more specific type.
Since you can't always be sure
what that more specific type is,
it's safest to use the conditional
typecast operator as?, like so.
And if we run it,
we can see that this avoids a crash.
And if we grab the second item in
the array instead of the first,
the cast succeeds and so
does the call to openDoor.